♪♪
Let's get to the news.
According to ex-White House
Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham's new book,
former President Trump
was once asked to go vegan for
charity.
But if you didn't
lose him at "vegan,"
I'm sure you lost him
at "charity."
In the same book, former Trump
administration's staffer
Stephanie Grisham describes the
White House as,
"A clown car on fire, running at
full speed into a warehouse
full of fireworks."
But she apparently doesn't
mention the part
where she called shotgun.
Former President Trump,
last week, called into
a prophecy-focused conservative
Christian talk show
and said "nobody has done more
for Christianity
or free evangelicals, or for
religion itself than I have."
Really? Nobody? You can't think
of a single person?
Jesus Christ.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
reportedly tells people
constantly that he's running for
President in 2024.
Well, he doesn't tell everyone,
it's your year, Mike.
After postponing
last week's vote
on the bipartisan infrastructure
package,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi on
Saturday set a new
Halloween deadline because
nothing is spookier
to Democrats than actually
passing legislation.
According to a recent survey 10%
of Americans said that they feel
very pessimistic about the rest
of 2021
while the other 90% said,
"It's 2021?"
Clint Eastwood, on Friday, won a
$6 million lawsuit
against a Lithuanian company
that used his image
to promote CBD products.
I'm not sure how they used his
image,
but I'm guessing as "Before"?
[ Laughter ]
Passengers on a Spirit Airline's
plane in Atlantic City,
New Jersey were forced to
deplane over the weekend
after a large bird
caused an engine fire.
And this is sad, that bird still
had a better time
than everyone who spent the
weekend in Atlantic City.
According to a new book, former
First Lady Melania Trump
obsessively read her own press
coverage because you can only
re-read your marriage contract
so many times.
And finally,
according to a new survey,
42% of Americans said that they
feel bad if they don't
do anything productive all day.
Fortunately, clicking this
counts as productive.
Facebook went offline yesterday
for over 6 hours.
Wow, they finally found
something
they couldn't fix
with horse past.
Facebook apologized yesterday
after all three
of its social media platforms
went offline for 6 hours.
And said it was due to a "faulty
configuration change."
Adding, "after a quick reboot,
he started working again."
President Biden said yesterday
that he couldn't guarantee
that the Federal Government will
not default on debt payments
due later this month, so in
addition to everything else
going on we've now entered
the "uncut gems" phase
of his presidency.
Right now he's on the phone at
the Bellagio saying,
"Put all of Montana on red."
During a Zoom session yesterday
with the House Progressive
Caucus,
President Biden reportedly said
that he's frustrated
with Senators Joe Manchin
and Kyrsten Sinema.
Well, you know it's bad when a
78-year-old man is on Zoom
and that's not
the frustrating part.
During a briefing yesterday,
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki showed a chart of how
much debt was accumulated
under former President Trump,
and said, "Republicans spent
like drunken sailors
over the last four years."
And in some cases they also
looked like them.
Former White House Press
Secretary Stephanie Grisham's
book was released today,
find it in
the "complicit but needs money"
section.
the New York Times published an
op-ed yesterday titled,
"What's Wrong With Kyrsten
Sinema?"
Well, for one thing, I think she
may be color blind.
Former presidential candidate
Andrew Yang announced yesterday
that he has changed his voting
registration from Democrat
to Independent,
raising the question,
if a tree falls in the woods
can we listen to that
instead of Andrew Yang?
And finally,
the rights to the Folgers
"the best part of waking up"
jingle recently sold at auction
for more than $90,000 while the
"Kars 4 Kids" jingle
was taken out back
and shot in the head.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer spoke yesterday
on the Senate floor and said
that the U.S. is getting
"dangerously close" to hitting
the debt ceiling,
which is scary because there has
never been a group of people
less likely to spontaneously
raise the roof.
President Biden had lunch today
with Vice President
Kamala Harris, and even that
bill couldn't get figured out.
In a new interview, ex-UN
Ambassador Nikki Haley
said that she calls former
President Trump a friend,
while Trump calls her "Linda."
The U.S. Capitol Police,
yesterday, forcibly removed
a man from a suspicious SUV
parked outside of
the Supreme Court,
they knew something was off
when the back window didn't have
this sticker on it.
That's right the Capitol Police
removed a man from a suspicious
SUV parked outside of the
Supreme Court,
the man was apparently so
suspicious Republicans want him
on the Supreme Court.
Facebook released a statement
yesterday explaining the cause
of Monday's 6-hour-long outage,
and man,
she is screwing everything up,
lately.
I unplugged the server so I
could charge my phone.
Not sorry.
Singer Adele, yesterday,
announced she'll release
a new single called "Easy On Me"
later this month.
Incidentally,
a new single is also
who's gonna listen to it
the most.
[ Laughter ]
Poor lady, take a stock photo.
She's like,
"This'll never come up."
[ Laughter ]
"They won't use this one."
More apartments in Manhattan
sold in the third quarter
of this year than any other time
in the last 32 years.
So now the only affordable
neighborhood in New York
is Wehu, meaning
"west of the Hudson"
and, yeah it's -- sorry --
it's New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
You have a view of Manhattan.
The fast food-chain Wendy's
announced a partnership with
Kellogg's yesterday
to release
a chocolate frosty-flavored
cereal.
Not to be outdone, McDonald's is
releasing a McFlurry cereal
that is temporarily
out of service.
And, finally, according to the
latest rankings,
former President Trump is no
longer on Forbes magazine's list
of the 400 richest Americans,
but on the right side,
he still made the list of the 46
greatest Presidents.
According to the latest poll
numbers, President Biden's
approval rating is 38% which is
the lowest it's been
since taking office.
Well, come on, America, what do
you want him to do? Something?
According to a new Senate report
former President Trump directly
asked the Justice Department on
nine separate occasions
to overturn the 2020 election.
Nine? Was he in the back seat of
the car?
"Will you overturn the
election?" "No!"
"Will you overturn the elect--?"
"No!"
"Will you overturn the e--?"
In her new book,
former White House
Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham writes
that Ivanka Trump used to ask
her to suppress unflattering
news stories about her.
Here's what
that would look like --
According to a new report,
former President Trump
did not want to use anesthesia
for his secret 2019 colonoscopy
because he did not want
Mike Pence to
temporarily assume power.
But joke's on him because
Mike Pence is anesthesia.
"Mr. President I just want to
sincerely thank you
for your leadership --
okay he's out."
Today was Russian President
Vladimir Putin's 69th birthday
and I think I know what he
wished for.
Universal Studios in Orlando has
announced that
the Shrek 4-D simulator show
will close next year
because it turns out, nobody
actually wanted to smell Shrek.
Netflix announced yesterday that
it will release 11 new
holiday movies before Christmas
and I think they're running low
on ideas.
And finally, in a new interview,
singer Meghan Trainor
said she and her husband have
two toilets next to each other
in their bathroom so they can
spend more time together.
In case you're wondering why
there was no
"stars, they're just like us"
section this week.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.